[Music]
Trump keeps scoring the dams still
boring I wonder what did Trump learn
from impeachment that the Democrats are
crooked they've got a lot of crooked
things going and that they're vicious
that they shouldn't have brought
impeachment mm anything else and then by
all numbers are ten points higher
because of fake news like NBC the
country the country kept thriving during
impeachment and America's starting to
notice you know how pollsters ask are
you better off than you were three years
ago this year sixty-one percent said yes
better off under Trump a number way
higher than when incumbents were up for
reelection Obama didn't get that high
well nor did Bush 43 or Clinton or Bush
41 Trump's number is so high I get a
nosebleed just reading it and that's
gonna be tough for any of the candidates
to beat honestly you think Trump's gonna
worry about this now if I were for Texas
I may say he says Donald Trump is scared
as a cat at the dog pound but since I'm
from New York I put it this way we're
scaring the living hell out of them and
we're just starting right now
I don't think Texans say that
and I don't think Trump is scared of
that even CNN knows a Trump victory in
November it's not that hard to get there
not that hard to get there because North
Carolina viewed as a swing state here
North Carolina tends to lean red in
presidential politics Florida in recent
elections leans red in presidential
politics Arizona Democrats think they
can win it this year let's see its
history is it leans red just those three
states get the President to 259 look at
the map he could get there easily just
by winning Pennsylvania again that would
get him over the top let's say that one
goes blue president could get there by
winning Michigan again that would get
him over the top he could do it with a
combination of New Hampshire and
Wisconsin so when you look at the map
now the president has a viable path you
know what you can't hear in the back
there is gone lemon quietly weeping I
guess the dams better find something
else to investigate like maybe president
Trump interfering in the Roger stone
case with a tweet but in case you
haven't noticed Trump tweets all the
time which means he interferes in
everything
Mike Bloomberg's a mass of dead energy
new stock market record spend your money
wisely great light up on Fox tonight
with Jesse Watters judge Jeanine and
Greg Gutfeld that's a real tweet
I'll tell ya you name it he's gonna
tweet it so the dentist we tried to
impeach Trump for this thing - it's all
they have especially when the majority
says they're better off then three years
ago when 90% of the country thinks my
life is good and when the first
impeachment didn't put a single dent in
Trump's armor are they gonna try it
again I hope so because I really miss
Adam Schiff if you were an Apple I
wouldn't pick you I'm gonna go slide
down a snowy mountain on my bare feet no
way that's not okay ready or not here I
Jess go Adam go so they call security
security prove it in a court of law
I say I have the light I recognize
myself
good night thoughts in general what do
you think in general I know president
Trump and it's he can never not say
something about people like he actually
brought me to the Lincoln Bedroom and I
was having an out-of-body experience I'm
looking at the Gettysburg Address and I
turned around and said he said you know
Rob not everybody gets to see this
unless the court should donate to the
Clinton Foundation I'm like you just
can't not just but it's funny um here in
Bloomberg talk because you know I like
to make jokes once in a while stealing
my jokes my number-one jokes never about
poop but it is always a solid number too
yeah ladies and gentlemen for all the
money that Bloomberg has he couldn't
found a comedian coach I mean he gave me
two hundred fifty thousand but I'll do
the jokes for you yeah but I mean he
literally said in Texas he was more
nervous than a cat yeah at a dog pound
dogs locked up jokes don't make it he
did and then he was like but how are we
doing in New York and you remember the
one guy in the crowd it was like the
entire place was like what sometimes
when people talk and they can't tell a
story it hurts so bad you can't look at
him yeah I guarantee you that entire
audience by the time you got the dog
pound were like and then you have to
look back to acknowledge because he's
looking at you you go let's go play is
when you don't have charisma or talent
and you're a billionaire yeah you buy it
bro exactly
I think he is paying for a cat but he's
getting lousy jokes yeah I think so too
yeah glorious like just he kind of it
like yeah because he probably has
somebody think about voting for a guy
who was like if I'm your president this
is going to happen and someone feeds you
ice cream yeah and then there's giant
gingerbread men flipping around yeah you
don't say with him riding a giant cat he
made he called from a dinosaur instead
we get like a cat in a dice Texas you
ain't talking about cows steers in
cowboy hats 40 Jack mark was that I'm
pretty sure they both just talked over
me the whole time but that was good that
cat is the one who killed bin Laden
[Laughter]
Cyrus I can't believe I'm around I can't
believe they found someone who tells a
joke worse than their candidate in 2016
because every time I came on this show
that time I used to do Hillary when
she'd be saying boy I wanna tell you and
she do they bobblehead presidential blue
bomber has to do is boy he's about as
scared of me
as a cat in a dog pound they'd fall over
and he'd had he'd get the Hillary
ovations and also Trump is funny yeah
like whether you like him don't like him
he's objectively hilarious and you're
not gonna be able to be funnier than he
is yes no and I'd say yeah that's a good
point you should be the guy who just
keeps saying that's not funny
yeah yeah because the Democrats are
actually a great humorless party they
say there's that they're the party of
the humorless they the people who say
that's not yeah I think it's good gloomy
and Trump it's a tortoise versus the
hare because he does look like a
tortoise Trump's got the hair
[Applause]